hello everyone and welcome to round 2 of
the 2013 candidates tournament as you've
seen in round one it was a pretty
peaceful round all of the games were
drawn but like I mentioned around to
already has a couple of surprises and I
believe in my previous video while I was
introducing the players I forgot to
introduce team or a job of probably
because I was planning to show you a job
of and only then Peter Svidler but then
while I was mixing up the photos I first
saw Peter Svidler and I forgot to show
you two more a job of but yeah he is the
eighth player of this candidates
tournament and this game he has the
white pieces against Vasilyev antic and
before we check out the game here we can
enjoy this nice photo of vastly von
Schuch posing for the photo and in the
back the murderer job of is preparing to
to join vastly for a game of chess so
that being said let's see this game and
chances are you've never seen this game
and those of you who have and might have
forgotten about it if you've if you've
been following the 2013 candidates
tournament as it was played but then
again you might have seen this game and
the chances are you haven't seen the
brilliancy that was missed in this game
but it will be a nice puzzle for you to
solve so let's see the game our job of
has the white pieces and he opens with
d4 we have d6 Knight to f3 and the g6 we
have C 4 and now f5 event rock is
setting up his Leningrad variation of
the Dutch Knight to c3 Knight to f6 we
have G 3 Bishop to g7 and Bishop to g2
and we've entered the Leningrad a
variation of the Dutch defense this is
the mainline event you
castles are a job of castles c6.r up to
b1 and Knight to e4 Queen to c2 by row
job of and here even she plays knife
captures on c3 and here a job of said
after the game that he thought that this
move was a mistake that it allows white
simply too much but this game was
already known at the time it was already
played I believe in 2011 between chronic
and Nakamura but ok B captors on c3 and
now event who goes a 5
immediately going for that center d
capture Sonny 5b chapters on e5 and
Bishop to a3 developing the bishop and
attacking the rook on f8 rook to f7 by
one choke and now rook F to d1 attacking
the Queen Queen to e8 and now e for and
here white is already complete is almost
completely developed the knight is
developed the Bishop occupies a nice
square depends on what happens here in
the center the bishop on e3 is a very
nice piece rockin d1 occupies an open
file a row can be one occupies a
semi-open file kind of preventing this
bishop from developing to d7 but all in
all eventually did kind of forget about
his development on the Queen side and he
decides to play f4 here and after after
some time a roof to d3 was played by her
job but he could immediately take
advantage of this f4 move by von Schuch
but it seems he trusted him and talked
about this being a good move by playing
Knight the g5 you can sort of take
advantage of this because after rook to
d7 rook captures on d7 you can't capture
with the bishop because rook captures on
b7 so you'd have to capture with the
night and then again all of your Queen
set development will be halted for some
time after c5 comes and an even worse
variation would be Queen captures on b7
Queen captures on d7 actually loses the
game for black but it's also a nice
position for you to analyze so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
a figure out why this is losing for
black at least the first move wise with
Queen captures and e7 such a problem for
black so I will give it a couple of
seconds for you to decide
for those of you who have found the
correct idea congratulations you are an
excellent attacker and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
the idea is c5 and now you see the
problem now we see this diagonal opens
up towards the black King Queen to b3
will be a lot of problems for black the
knight is nicely placed on g5 bush of to
h3 is also an idea
so after black plays something like
Queen to e8 so Queen to b3 the King
come to a fete and queen to f7 will not
be such a problem or night captures on
h7 rock capture some b7 outcomes and now
black blacks position is completely
shattered you can't capture the rook you
have to play something especially if you
capture drugged and Queen to b3 is is
deadly immediately King f8 Queen and
Knight captures on h7 check out King
moves now Queen captures here Queen
blocks and now you even lose the rook
and completely winning position for
white but yeah I mean this doesn't have
to happen this only happens if Queen
captures on b7 but again still if Knight
to d7 and c5 would make a game very very
difficult for black but ok a job of
played rock to d3 he didn't go for 9 g5
immediately F capture son g3 H captures
and g3 and night to a6 now event chip
tries to tries to develop his Queen side
pieces nice to g5 now comes and here
instead of going rook to d7 and going
pretty much into what we just seen event
should please rock the c7 he invites our
job of to go for Bishop to d6 and even
took prepares a nice exchange sacrifice
so Bishop to d6 was played by a job of
and here if you go rock to d7 then this
is a bit of a problem then c5 comes
again your Bishop is beautiful here on
d6 Queen to b3 will be an idea again for
example h6 Queen b3 check King moves and
now Knight comes to e6 rock to f7
attacking the knight and now Bishop to
h3 and this position is beautiful for
white this will be a slow death for
black so after Bishop to d6 aventure
doesn't move the rook
instead he plays Bishop to f6 he attacks
the undefended knight on d5 so offering
offering a piece here there's really no
no hidden secret here why when she gives
up the rook if Bishop captures then
Knight captures that's that's pretty
much it the night is still a tec-9 of
three and now the idea is that Evancho's
bishop pair will be enough to compensate
for for a job of winning the d file and
the Viper will will prevent him the
double rooks from infiltrating a matrix
position on the D file so instead after
Bishop to d6 event took place Bishop to
f6 and now a javo declines this he
doesn't want the rook
instead he plays Queen to d2 he
increases pressure on the D file and
also protects the knight on d5 now event
took place
rook to d7 as the knight is no longer
attacked on g5 and the now comes in
Bishop to h3 attacking the rook rook
toss a rope to g7 and here Bishop
captures on e5 so what's the idea here
of course you cannot capture you cannot
capture the put the Queen if you play
Queen captures then you immediately lose
this game because rook to b8 will will
be checkmate in three moves but should
capture screen captures and now as you
see Knight this Knight is guarding f7
you have to block this and then Queen
captures and this will be checkmate
so after Bishop captures another option
is maybe Bishop captures on g5 but this
is this is this is much better
and now Queen captures and after Bishop
captures on h3 Bishop captures on g7 and
you cannot grab the bishop on g7
unfortunately for black if you do then
Bishop rook capture some b7 will be dead
King h8 Queen f6 easy checkmate or black
will have to lose a lot of material so
after Bishop captures on e5 Avant you
decided to play Bishop captures on e5
and he decides to sacrifice his Queen
rook to d8
now the queen is under attack there's no
way to move the Queen as the Queen is
pinned Bishop captures on h3 now rook
captures rook captures and Knight
captures on h3 right to the c5 and now
okay the b7 pawn is now nicely defended
by the night and by the rook and
eventual does does have material for for
lacking a queen but it's it's a better
position for a white but still a job of
Hester has to work for his win Queen to
e3 attacking the knight now Bishop to d6
defending f3 we are nice to b6 King to
g2 and now g5 event
two rooks and he wants to break open on
the kingside Knights to f2 we have h
five Queen captures on H on a7 and
Bishop to c5 now attacking the Queen
Queen to a4 and now comes Rock to f8
night to d3 attacking the bishop we have
h 4 now and here Queen to a5 of course
you don't want to capture here if if
captures captures this opens up a
discovered check from the rook came to H
2 and now rook captures on f3 and it's
pretty much a drawn position but you
know when under such heavy fire it's
easy it's easy to overlook a checkmate
but ok after h4 Queen to a5 with a
double attack on the Bishop b6 here and
this is the the magic position that
everyone talked about after this game
here Rajah the flayed row to capture
some b6 and avenge was in serious time
trouble here I want to play Bishop
capture some b6 and here after Queen
captures and H captors and g3 he want to
display H captures and g3 but in the
meantime his the the clock the time on
his clock ran out and here even to close
the game on time and it's a better
position for white so I guess it's a
it's a deserving win for team or raja
baath but this brings us to the very
important line that was missed instead
of after Roger who played would capture
some b6 instead of playing Bishop
capture some b6 we have a brilliant move
that was missed and that allows a vastly
to actually draw the game so vastly did
have an excuse it was very low on time
but you have all the time in the world
so feel free to pause the video see the
video here and find the drawing idea for
a von Schuch so I will give it a couple
of seconds as usual for those of you who
are able to find the move
congratulations it's it's really a
incredibly hard move to find the move
here that draws the game from Ashley is
g4 and the g4 draws the game because
well let's check out some of some of the
responses F captors on g4
leads to bushel capture some b6 Queen
captures and rook captures on g4 and
I'll pretty much anything you do between
captures will easily draw the game
check check check check if you try King
H 2 then knife comes here and again you
will get checks checks here and back and
Queen G sex is nothing King King King
can simply move back another idea after
g4 as what happens if Knight captures on
c5 white simply decides okay I'm just
gonna grab a free piece well then a
white loses the game horribly because G
captors on f3 King moves and now Knight
to g4 Knight to g5 check King captures
and now f2 and you can't really stop the
pawn rook to be one good ideas of giving
up the rock for a pawn but Knight f3
check King moves and now Knight to e1
and there is no way of stopping point
point to f1 and this will be a queen so
and and white is gaining checkmate it
very soon whatever you play so the only
thing that remains after this g4 move is
white what if white plays the strongest
f4 well then comes the brilliancy h3
check and now it doesn't matter where
the King goes if you go King h1 then the
move you really have to find rook to d7
attacking the undefended Knight and
black will simply capture this night and
then go rook d1 and if you remove the
night for example Knight captures here
at again win a free piece then you're
getting checkmated ruled e1 check King
moves and now Knight to g5 and whatever
move white makes it really doesn't
matter if as there is no useful move
Knight to f3 will be checkmate so a very
nice idea and like I said it doesn't
matter here if you go King h1 you can go
even king h2 it doesn't really matter
again the idea is the same rook d7 and
still if you capture the bishop we go
into the same variation so let's try
this rope capture c6 a rope captures and
then let's say look after c5 room d2
check King moves knife capture screen
captures and then this will be a draw by
repetition if you go if you go even
further with the King then the H bone
will be even winning
so yeah a very nice game and the very
nice 140 motor job of but you know I
really wanted to show you this game and
hopefully hopefully some of you were
able to find it the g4 move so yeah
that's the game team or Java versus
vastly buncha from round 202 2013
candidates tournament I do hope you
enjoyed it and we will show one more
game from round two and then we'll we'll
say something more about the other games
that were played so yeah as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon with another video from this
championship thank you